I'm sorry. Those may be some of the simplest and yet most powerful words in the English language, with the potentially heal relationships, soothe hurt feelings, and even begin to write historical wrongs. But they're not always easy to say, or to say sincerely. Most of us know the feeling of an apology sticking in our throat, even when we realize how much the person or people whom we've hurt would like to hear it. So why are apologies so important in relationships, and why it often hard to apologize? What makes for a good, effective apology, and what makes for a bad one? Are some apologies so bad that they're worse than no apology at all? Why do some people find it easier to apologize than others? And what about when you're the victim rather than the offender?
我很抱歉。这可能是英语中最简单却最有力量的几个词，它们有可能修复人际关系、抚平受伤的情感，甚至开始弥补历史错误。但它们并不总是那么容易说出口，或者说得真诚。我们大多数人都体会过道歉卡在喉咙里的感觉，即使我们意识到被我们伤害的人有多么渴望听到它。那么，为什么道歉在人际关系中如此重要？为什么道歉往往很难？什么才算是一个好的、有效的道歉，什么又是一个糟糕的道歉？有些道歉是否糟糕到还不如不道歉？为什么有些人比其他人更容易道歉？当你不是冒犯者而是受害者时，情况又会怎样？
If someone wants to apologize to you, but you're not ready to forgive them, what do you do? Also, is there any truth to the stereotype that women apologize more than men do? And finally, what about Apologies in the public sphere? What's the difference between public and private apologies? Is there a role for institutional and government apologies in addressing historical injustice and atrocities? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Karina Schumann, an associate professor of psychology and chair of the Social Psychology Program at the University of Pittsburgh. She studies conflict resolution,
如果有人想向你道歉，但你还没准备好原谅他们，你该怎么办？此外，关于女性比男性道歉更多的刻板印象有道理吗？最后，公共领域的道歉又如何呢？公共道歉和私人道歉有什么区别？机构和政府的道歉在解决历史不公正和暴行方面是否发挥作用？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是卡琳娜·舒曼博士，她是匹兹堡大学心理学副教授兼社会心理学项目主任。她研究冲突解决、
apologies, and forgiveness, including the interrelated psychological experiences of harming others and being harmed by others. Her work addresses many of the questions I just posed about how people respond to each other in conflicts and how those responses affect their relationships and their well-being. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Schumann. My pleasure. Thank you for having me. On your lab's website, you write that one of the unfortunate certainties of life is that we sometimes hurt people we care about, and they sometimes hurt us. When people do inevitably hurt each other, how important are apologies to healing those rifts? What role do apologies play in our relationships? They're incredibly important. Apologies really can be thought of as the super glue of life in a way. I've heard that quote before.
道歉和宽恕，包括伤害他人和被他人伤害的相互关联的心理体验。她的工作涉及我刚才提出的许多问题，即人们在冲突中如何相互回应，以及这些回应如何影响他们的人际关系和幸福感。感谢您今天加入我，舒曼博士。不客气，谢谢你的邀请。在你们实验室的网站上，你写道，生活中不幸的确定性之一就是我们有时会伤害我们在乎的人，而他们有时也会伤害我们。当人们不可避免地互相伤害时，道歉对于修复这些裂痕有多重要？道歉在我们的关系中扮演什么角色？它们非常重要。在某种程度上，道歉真的可以被认为是生活的强力胶。我以前听过那句话。
They really go a long way to show concern, to show that you care about the relationship, about the person, that you want to make things right. And they're not always perfect, as you said in your introduction. Some apologies are lacking quite a bit. But if they're given from the heart and if they're really genuine and sincere in the way they're offered and in their intention, even if the words aren't perfect, they can go a really long way to showing the person that you care about them and that you want to make amends and repair the relationship to what it was before the harm was done. And so for that reason,
它们确实在很大程度上表达了关心，表明你在乎这段关系，在乎这个人，并且你想弥补过错。正如你在介绍中所说，它们并不总是完美的。有些道歉确实相当欠缺。但如果它们是发自内心的，如果它们在提供的方式和意图上确实是真诚的，即使措辞不够完美，它们也能在很大程度上向对方表明你在乎他们，并且你想弥补过错，将关系修复到伤害发生之前的状态。因此，出于这个原因，
apologies are one of the most powerful tools that people can use in their lives to smooth over their relationships, whether it's for a small little insult or joke that was unintentionally harmful or for something really major and severe. that can destroy a relationship. Apologies have been known to be really, really powerful in terms of repairing the relationship, helping people get on track, and really being the start of a longer process of reconciliation for some of those more severe offenses. And so in the research that we do, we show that apologies are incredibly effective, especially to the extent that they are sincere and perceived as sincere by the victim or the person on the receiving end, and that they do a
道歉是人们生活中用来缓和人际关系的最强大的工具之一，无论是针对无意中造成伤害的小小冒犯或玩笑，还是针对可能破坏关系的重大且严重的事件。众所周知，道歉在修复关系、帮助人们重回正轨方面非常、非常强大，对于一些更严重的冒犯，它们确实是更长期的和解过程的开始。因此，在我们所做的研究中，我们表明道歉是非常有效的，特别是当它们真诚且被受害者或接收方认为真诚时，它们确实
lot to promote forgiveness, to create healing in the relationship, and to reduce anger and revenge motivation in the victim. So what makes for an effective apology, is there essentially a formula for a really good apology? No formula, I'd say. It's going to depend quite a bit on the situation your relationship with the other person, the offense that was committed, how severe it was. I would say the absolutely most important thing to remember when apologizing is to try to be authentic and sincere in the way you're offering it and in what you're communicating to the other person. There are certainly key components of an apology that the person who is harmed will look for and will want to hear. things like those two very important words, I'm sorry or I apologize, are a really strong signal that you are apologizing. Sometimes people will think they've apologized by saying something like,
在促进宽恕、创造关系中的治愈，以及减少受害者的愤怒和报复动机方面发挥了很大作用。那么，什么才算是一个有效的道歉？本质上有一个好的道歉公式吗？我想说没有公式。这在很大程度上取决于具体情况、你与对方的关系、所犯的冒犯以及它的严重程度。我想说，道歉时最重要的事情是尽量在提供道歉的方式以及与对方沟通的内容上保持真实和真诚。道歉确实有一些关键组成部分，受害者会寻找并希望听到。像“我很抱歉”或“我道歉”这两个非常重要的词，是一个非常强烈的信号，表明你在道歉。有时人们会认为他们已经道歉了，通过说类似的话，
oops, shouldn't have done that. And the other person's like, well, that's not an apology because they haven't heard those key words that they really associate with an apology and an expression of remorse. So you want to send that very clear signal. Other things that are really important are some sort of acceptance of responsibility or accountability for the offense. Victims really want to hear that you are accepting some of the blame for what happened, taking responsibility for the offense. And that signals to them that you know that what you did was offensive and that you're willing to accept some of that blame. And that takes some of the blame away from the victim as well. Because sometimes it can be an ambiguous situation.
“哎呀，我不该那样做。”而对方会觉得，嗯，那不是道歉，因为他们没有听到他们真正与道歉和悔意表达联系在一起的关键词。所以你想发出那个非常明确的信号。其他非常重要的事情是对冒犯承担某种责任或问责。受害者确实想听到你正在为发生的事情承担部分责任，为冒犯承担责任。这向他们发出信号，表明你知道你的所作所为是冒犯性的，并且你愿意承担部分责任。这也减轻了受害者身上的一些责任。因为有时这可能是一个模糊的情况。
And by accepting responsibility, it disambiguates that. An acknowledgement of harm is something that I think is really underused. People tend to forget to empathize with the other person and say, wow, I see how this has affected you. These are the ways in which you're suffering because of what I've done or because of the way you've been inconvenienced by this. And that validation is really important for the person to hear that you understand that this is how they've been harmed and that you see.
通过承担责任，它消除了这种模糊性。对伤害的承认是我认为被严重低估的一点。人们往往忘记与对方产生共鸣，并说：“哇，我看到了这对我造成的影响。这些就是因为我的所作所为，或者因为你被这件事困扰而遭受痛苦的方式。”这种认可对于对方听到你理解他们是如何受到伤害的，以及你看到了，
the consequences of your actions for them. And that's something that when, you know, we code people's apologies in our research, it doesn't show up as often as you think or as you would expect, given how much we probably want to hear that when we're on the receiving end of an apology. But for some reason, we neglect to include that in our apologies. About, you know, 85 to 90 percent of the apologies that I code don't include that. And I think it's a really critical component. I think it's one with other elements if you want, or you can jump in No, I just wanted to ask what makes a bad apology because I can think of a lot of instances when people have made public apologies, particularly politicians, and they'll say, well,
你行为对他们造成的后果，是非常重要的。这是我们在研究中对人们的道歉进行编码时，发现它出现的频率并不像你想象的或预期的那样高，考虑到当我们处于道歉的接收端时，我们可能有多么想听到这些。但出于某种原因，我们在道歉中忽略了这一点。大约85%到90%我编码的道歉都不包含这一点。我认为这是一个非常关键的组成部分。我认为它是与其他要素结合在一起的，如果你愿意的话，或者你可以插话。不，我只是想问什么构成了糟糕的道歉，因为我能想到很多人们进行公开道歉的例子，特别是政客，他们会说，嗯，
if you were offended, I'm sorry, which sort of puts it on the recipient of whatever the offense was instead of, you know, I did a bad thing. It's really your fault because you were upset by what I said. Yes, that is a common apology that we hear. And it's tempting, right? You want to say, oh, if something happens that you're hurt by, then I'm sorry for that. And it kind of removes that requirement of taking responsibility, right? You're not saying, I did this and this was wrong. You're saying, I'm expressing remorse. I'm expressing some sympathy for what this person is going through, but I'm not going so far as to take accountability for it. And people do not like to receive apologies like that. That specific way of saying it, you know, if something happened,
“如果你感到被冒犯了，我很抱歉”，这在某种程度上把责任推给了无论什么冒犯的接收者，而不是说“我做了一件坏事”。“这真的是你的错，因为你对我说的话感到不安。”是的，这是我们经常听到的常见道歉。这很诱人，对吧？你想说，哦，如果发生了什么事让你受伤了，那么我对此感到抱歉。这在某种程度上消除了承担责任的要求，对吧？你不是在说，“我做了这件事，这是错的。”你是在说，“我正在表达悔意。我正在对这个人正在经历的事情表达一些同情，但我不会走得那么远去为此承担责任。”人们不喜欢收到那样的道歉。那种特定的说法，你知道，“如果发生了什么事，
Then I'm sorry. That's the worst case scenario because you're really not even aware, it seems, of what was wrong. You're not acknowledging how the person was harmed. You're not accepting responsibility. So it's really showing that you're not in tune with that person. And there really isn't a strong sense of empathy or concern that comes across because you're not even aware of what you've done. That was harmful. And then the other version that that comes in is, I'm sorry that this hurt you or I'm sorry that you were offended by this. And again, that is pushing. It's shifting the blame onto the victim in a way by saying you're sensitive and you were hurt by this.
那么我很抱歉。”这是最坏的情况，因为你似乎甚至没有意识到哪里出了问题。你没有承认对方是如何受到伤害的。你没有承担责任。所以这确实表明你与那个人不在同一个频道上。而且并没有强烈的同理心或关怀感传达出来，因为你甚至没有意识到你做了什么。那是伤害性的。然后出现的另一个版本是，“我很抱歉这伤害了你”或“我很抱歉你对此感到被冒犯了”。同样，这在某种程度上是在推卸责任，把责任推给受害者，说你很敏感，你被这件事伤害了。
It's not because of what I did that was wrong. It's because of your reaction to it. And again, that doesn't really sit well with the person on the receiving end who really wants to hear. I recognize that what I did was wrong and I put you in this position of being on the receiving end of this harmful behavior and that was wrong of me. And so this can be tricky, especially when someone wants to smooth things over but they really don't feel like they're responsible. How do you express remorse and empathize and offer that apology without inauthentically taking responsibility? So I think a good thing in those kinds of situations is to really try to put yourself in a position to empathize with the person and what they're going through.
这不是因为我做错了什么。这是因为你的反应。同样，这在接收端的人听来并不舒服，他们真正想听到的是：“我承认我做错了，我让你处于这种受到伤害行为影响的位置，这是我的错。”所以这可能很棘手，特别是当有人想缓和关系但他们真的不觉得他们有责任时。你如何在不虚假地承担责任的情况下表达悔意、产生共鸣并提供道歉？所以我认为在那种情况下，一件好事是真正尝试让自己处于能够与对方产生共鸣的位置，去理解他们正在经历什么。
So you might ask them, you know, I'd really like to learn from the situation and why this, you know, was hurtful to you. Can you explain to me what you're feeling so that I can better understand? And maybe by, you know, seeking that perspective and asking for that information, you might have a better sense of what their experience was like. And that might help you understand the situation better from their vantage point, which might then allow you to authentically take responsibility for your actions a little bit better. A lot of people find it difficult to apologize, even when they know how much it would mean to the other person. What are the barriers? What are the psychological barriers that keep people from apologizing? There's a few, yeah.
所以你可以问他们，你知道，“我真的很想从这种情况中学习，为什么这让你感到受伤。你能向我解释一下你的感受吗，以便我能更好地理解？”也许通过寻求那种视角并询问这些信息，你可能会更好地了解他们的经历是什么样的。这可能会帮助你从他们的角度更好地理解情况，这可能会让你更真实地为自己的行为承担责任。很多人发现道歉很困难，即使他们知道这对对方意味着什么。障碍是什么？是什么心理障碍阻止人们道歉？有几个，是的。
So the foremost barrier is when we morally disengage from our actions. right? So this happens even when, so this is the situation where it's like, well, I didn't do anything wrong. You know, I shouldn't apologize. Why should I take responsibility for this? There's nothing that I did here that deserves an apology. And this is a very common response that we have. When we've done something wrong, this does not feel good to us. We want to push away blame from ourselves. And we can do this in a variety of ways. We blame the other person. We blame the situation. We think about all the you know, extenuating circumstances that affects your behavior or we minimize the consequences of the actions that we took for that other person. And all of those ways of morally disengaging
所以首要的障碍是当我们从道德上与我们的行为脱节时，对吧？所以这甚至发生在，所以这是那种情况，就像，“嗯，我没做错什么。你知道，我不应该道歉。我为什么要为此承担责任？我在这里所做的没有任何值得道歉的地方。”这是我们经常有的反应。当我们做错事时，这让我们感觉不好。我们想把责任从自己身上推开。我们可以通过多种方式做到这一点。我们责怪对方。我们责怪情况。我们考虑所有那些影响你行为的减轻情节，或者我们淡化我们采取的行动对那个人造成的后果。所有这些道德脱节的方式
allows us to say, well, there's nothing that needs to be, to be corrected here. I'm in the right. Those, that tendency to justify our actions that sort of comes first. And often, if that's the case, then we really won't feel an apology is necessary and therefore won't apologize. But even when we do recognize that we've done something wrong and that an apology might be warranted in the situation, there are barriers in those situations as well. One barrier is when we don't really care enough about the other person or the relationship to put ourselves out there on that limb, to make ourselves vulnerable through an apology to go that extra mile to repair the relationship. You know, this can sometimes with an acquaintance, a stranger, a colleague, you know, we don't really care to fix that relationship. or we're having a hard time empathizing with that person, even if it's someone we do care about.
让我们说，“嗯，这里没有什么需要纠正的。我是对的。”那种为我们的行为辩护的倾向是首先出现的。通常，如果是这种情况，那么我们真的不会觉得道歉是必要的，因此也就不会道歉。但即使当我们确实认识到我们做错了，并且在这种情况下道歉可能是合理的，这些情况下也存在障碍。一个障碍是当我们不够关心对方或这段关系，不足以让自己冒险，通过道歉让自己变得脆弱，去付出额外的努力来修复关系。你知道，这有时会发生在熟人、陌生人、同事身上，你知道，我们并不真的关心去修复那段关系。或者我们很难与那个人产生共鸣，即使是我们关心的人。
And so, for example, my research shows that as empathy fluctuates in your romantic relationships for various offenses, you become more or less likely to apologize. When you empathize a lot with your partner, you offer them an apology in that situation when you're less likely to empathize with them in that situation, you're less likely to apologize. Okay, so that's a lack of concern as a barrier.
所以，例如，我的研究表明，随着你在浪漫关系中对各种冒犯的同理心波动，你道歉的可能性也会随之增加或减少。当你对伴侣产生很多共鸣时，你会在那种情况下向他们道歉；当你在那种情况下不太可能对他们产生共鸣时，你就不太可能道歉。好的，所以缺乏关怀是一个障碍。
A second barrier is when you really feel like apologizing would be threatening to yourself. Now, we all have this very strong motivation to feel good about ourselves, to feel that we're good people, we're moral people. And so even when we have recognized that we've done something potentially wrong here, we have a desire to not associate ourselves with that wrongdoing. And apologizing explicitly does that, right? So when you apologize, you're explicitly associating yourself with some sort of inappropriate, immoral, incompetent behavior. And that does not feel good for ourselves. And so especially in anticipation of apologizing, we think, oh, I don't want to do this.
第二个障碍是当你真的觉得道歉会威胁到你自己时。现在，我们都有这种非常强烈的动机去感觉良好，去感觉我们是好人，我们是道德高尚的人。所以即使我们已经认识到我们在这里做了潜在的错事，我们也有一个愿望，不想把自己与那种不当行为联系起来。而道歉明确地做到了这一点，对吧？所以当你道歉时，你明确地将自己与某种不适当的、不道德的、无能的行为联系起来。这让我们感觉不好。所以特别是在预期道歉时，我们想，“哦，我不想这样做。”
This is uncomfortable. This makes me feel vulnerable. This makes me feel like a bad person to, you know, connect myself or to recognize that my actions were wrong. And so we might do other things like justify our actions or minimize the harm of our actions. And that feels really good in the moment, but it does not go very far towards reconciling the relationship. And then another barrier that comes into place is pretty simple. We just don't think apologies will be beneficial. Maybe we don't think that person will forgive us,
“这很不舒服。这让我感到脆弱。这让我觉得像个坏人，去承认我的行为是错的。”所以我们可能会做其他事情，比如为我们的行为辩护或淡化我们行为的伤害。这在当下感觉很好，但它对和解关系并没有多大帮助。然后另一个出现的障碍很简单。我们只是不认为道歉会有益。也许我们不认为那个人会原谅我们，
or we think that the offense was too severe for an apology to be really beneficial. And so we might not feel that it's worth the effort to put ourselves out there because we don't think it will have an impact. And there's research by some other great researchers, Lunason and colleagues, that shows that people have a tendency to overestimate the negative consequences of apologizing and underestimate the benefits of apologizing. But once we've actually apologized, we feel so much better, the other person feels better, and it can really have a positive impact. Well, talking about the other person, you know, we've been talking more about the person who apologizes, but what if you're the victim of the transgression? What do you do if somebody
或者我们认为冒犯太严重，道歉不会有真正的益处。所以我们可能觉得不值得付出努力去冒险，因为我们认为它不会产生影响。有一些其他伟大的研究人员，卢纳森和同事的研究表明，人们倾向于高估道歉的负面后果，而低估道歉的好处。但一旦我们真正道歉了，我们感觉好多了，对方也感觉更好，它确实能产生积极的影响。嗯，谈到对方，你知道，我们一直在谈论道歉的人，但如果你是违规行为的受害者呢？如果有人
apologize us to you, but you're not really ready to forgive them? I think this is really important because we have such a strong social script, such a strong link in our society between apologies and forgiveness. And part of that is because apologies do often lead to forgiveness. They really help the forgiveness process. But I suppose the downside of that really strong link is that victims might often feel pressured to forgive before they're ready. And the apologizer, the transgressor in the situation, might put expectations on the victim to forgive them once they've apologized. And I think this can add more insult to injury. This can create unhealthy expectations for the victim to forgive, both self-expectations and expectations from the transgressor, before a process of true reconciliation
向你道歉，但你还没准备好原谅他们，你该怎么办？我认为这非常重要，因为在我们的社会中，道歉和宽恕之间有如此强烈的社会脚本，如此强烈的联系。部分原因是道歉确实经常导致宽恕。它们确实有助于宽恕过程。但我认为这种强烈联系的负面影响是，受害者可能经常感到在准备好之前就被迫原谅。而道歉者，即这种情况下的违规者，可能会对受害者施加原谅他们的期望，一旦他们道歉了。我认为这可能会在伤口上撒盐。这可能会为受害者创造不健康的期望，即在真正的和解过程发生之前，
has been allowed to happen. And so transgressors, my advice, you know, is always for transgressors to apologize without this contingency of an expectation of forgiveness. You know, you're apologizing because you know it's the right thing to do because you care about the other person, because you want to help the relationship, not because you want to just get them to forgive you, right? It can't be used as a manipulation tactic like that. And you have to give the victim space to forgive.
必须原谅，既有自我期望，也有来自违规者的期望。所以违规者，我的建议总是让违规者在没有这种期望宽恕的偶然性的情况下道歉。你知道，你道歉是因为你知道这是正确的事情，因为你在乎对方，因为你想帮助这段关系，而不是因为你只是想让他们原谅你，对吧？它不能像那样被用作操纵策略。你必须给受害者宽恕的空间。
You have to give them space and time. And maybe that forgiveness will never come, depending on how severe this offense is and how damage the relationship is. And that's okay. You know, that can't be expected. And then from the person on the receiving end of the apology, it's really important to allow yourself that space and time to heal
你必须给他们空间和时间。也许那种宽恕永远不会到来，取决于这种冒犯有多严重以及关系受损的程度。那没关系。你知道，那不能被强求。然后从道歉的接收端的人来看，给自己留出空间和时间来治愈是非常重要的，
and to go and to expect more and have the candid conversation with the apologizer, the transgressor, about what you need to properly reconcile, because an apology might not be enough. I like to think of apologies as a really important starting point on the path of reconciliation, especially for more harmful offenses, where they signal concern,
并去期待更多，并与道歉者、违规者进行坦诚的对话，关于你需要什么才能适当地和解，因为道歉可能是不够的。我喜欢把道歉看作是和解道路上一个非常重要的起点，特别是对于更严重的冒犯，它们发出关怀的信号，
they signal accountability, they signal a commitment to doing better and wanting to change and wanting to improve in the relationship. But, you know, that apology has to be followed by actions that demonstrate that commitment to improvement and change. And so I'm thinking about obviously more severe offenses here, like infidelity or a continued pattern of psychological harm in a relationship or neglecting someone and constantly undermining the relationship
它们发出问责的信号，它们发出致力于做得更好、想要改变和想要改善关系的承诺的信号。但是，你知道，那个道歉必须伴随着证明那种改善和改变承诺的行动。所以我在这里显然是在考虑更严重的冒犯，比如不忠，或者关系中持续的心理伤害模式，或者忽视某人并不断破坏关系，
or continued, you know, failure to complete your obligations at work or something along those lines, right? Where you need to demonstrate not just an apology, but demonstrate that you really care about that person through behavioral change as well. And so for the victim who receives an apology who isn't ready to forgive, you can say that. You can say, I'm not quite ready yet. I need more time or I need you to do this and show me that you really care about me by changing your behavior. I thank you for your apology.
或者持续的，你知道，未能完成你在工作中的义务或类似的事情，对吧？你需要证明的不仅仅是一个道歉，还要通过行为改变来证明你真的在乎那个人。所以对于收到道歉但还没准备好原谅的受害者，你可以那样说。你可以说：“我还没完全准备好。我需要更多时间，或者我需要你这样做，通过改变你的行为向我证明你真的在乎我。我感谢你的道歉。”
I appreciate the effort. I know apologies aren't easy. and I appreciate this as a starting point, but here's what I need for us to move forward. And so just having that open, constructive communication, I think, can be really healthy in a relationship and allow the victim to feel like they have the agency over their own healing without feeling this unnecessary pressure, which can actually create more harm for them. And it sounds like not shutting down the person who is trying to apologize. keeping the door open to considering this.
“我感谢你的努力。我知道道歉并不容易。我感谢这是作为一个起点，但这是我为了让我们前进所需要的。”所以只要有那种开放、建设性的沟通，我认为在一段关系中是非常健康的，并允许受害者觉得他们对自己治愈的过程拥有代理权，而不会感到这种不必要的压力，这实际上会给他们造成更多的伤害。听起来不要拒绝试图道歉的人。保持开放的态度来考虑这一点。
Definitely. Yeah, I think that's really important. And that's where that communication comes in. Because if the person apologizes and you just continue to be unresponsive and you don't even acknowledge it, then that can really make them feel like their efforts aren't being acknowledged. And they might throw their hands up in the air and say, well, why bother? Right. And that might, you know, really inhibit them from engaging in those actions that you want to see those positive changes that you're hoping for because they think, well, they're
绝对的。是的，我认为这非常重要。这就是沟通发挥作用的地方。因为如果那个人道歉了，而你只是继续没有回应，甚至不承认，那么这真的会让他们觉得他们的努力没有得到认可。他们可能会摊开双手说，“好吧，何必呢？”对吧。这可能会，你知道，真的抑制他们参与你想要看到的那些行动，那些你所希望的积极改变，因为他们认为，“好吧，他们
they're already out the door. They don't care about this relationship. They're not committed to me either because they're not willing to forgive me. And so that's where that constructive communication comes in to say, look, let's work on this together. I'm not ready, but I can see a future or, you know, this is what I need to potentially get there. And I might not ever get there. But this is, this is what I at least am feeling right now. And I want us to potentially collaborate on this together. And like you said, that leaves that door open and they think can really create a willingness from the transgressor side as well to work with the victim to try to improve things. These days, we have so many media available to us to use to communicate. And I'm wondering if people find it easier to apologize in writing rather than in person.
他们已经准备离开了。他们不在乎这段关系。他们也不致力于我，因为他们不愿意原谅我。”所以这就是建设性沟通发挥作用的地方，去说，“看，让我们一起努力解决这个问题。我还没准备好，但我能看到未来，或者，你知道，这就是我为了潜在地达到那个目标所需要的。我可能永远达不到那个目标。但这是，这是我目前至少感受到的。我希望我们能潜在地在这方面合作。”就像你说的，这留下了那扇门，他们认为这确实能从违规者那边创造出一种意愿，去与受害者合作，尝试改善事情。如今，我们有如此多的媒体可供我们使用来进行交流。我想知道人们是否发现书面道歉比当面道歉更容易。
What about apologizing via text? Are these kinds of apologies as effective as an in? in-person apology or as meaningful? You know, there's not a lot of research on this, and I had started doing some research on this with an honors student. We didn't have clear answers emerge, and to be fair, we didn't run too many studies on this, but I think the answer right now is we don't know. There isn't a ton of research on it, but, you know, what we do know very, very clearly
通过短信道歉怎么样？这些道歉像当面道歉一样有效吗？或者一样有意义吗？你知道，关于这方面的研究并不多，我曾开始与一名荣誉学生做一些这方面的研究。我们没有得出明确的答案，公平地说，我们没有在这方面进行太多的研究，但我认为现在的答案是我们不知道。关于它的研究并不多，但是，你知道，我们非常、非常清楚地知道
from decades of research on apologies is that sincerity matters the most. And so if your typical way of communicating with someone is text messaging, and that seems totally normal for you two to communicate that way, even about important things, then if you're sincere in the words you use and you put in a lot of, you know, augmenters, I'm so sorry. I really, really, you know, want to express how genuinely remorseful I am and those kinds of things. and you communicate that emotion through text and that's normal for your relationship, then I don't see why it wouldn't be effective. I think where the medium that you're using might matter is where, you know, you're used to seeing this person all the time face to face.
从几十年的道歉研究中，最重要的是真诚。所以，如果你与某人沟通的典型方式是短信，而且你们俩以那种方式沟通看起来完全正常，即使是关于重要的事情，那么如果你在你使用的词语中是真诚的，并且你投入了很多，你知道，增强语，“我太抱歉了。我真的、真的，你知道，想表达我是多么真诚地感到悔恨”之类的话，并且你通过短信传达那种情感，这对你们的关系来说是正常的，那么我不明白为什么它不会有效。我认为你使用的媒介可能很重要的地方是，你知道，你习惯于一直面对面地见到这个人。
You rarely communicate important things by email or text and all of a sudden they're getting this, this, you know, text out of the blue, which might feel like either, you know, you're not brave enough to face them or you don't care. enough to put in the effort. And so I would say, you know, stick to what feels comfortable for your relationship and normal for your relationship. But most of all, think about how can I convey sincerity and concern in this in this apology? I mentioned in my introduction that there's a stereotype that women apologize more than men do. And I know you've done research in this area. Can you tell our listeners what you have found? Is that stereotype true? Yes and no. So, yes.
你们很少通过电子邮件或短信沟通重要的事情，突然之间他们收到了这个，这个，你知道，突如其来的短信，这可能会让人觉得要么，你知道，你不够勇敢去面对他们，要么你不在乎。投入足够的努力。所以我建议，你知道，坚持那些对你们的关系感觉舒适且正常的方式。但最重要的是，思考我如何能在这次道歉中传达真诚和关怀？我在介绍中提到，有一种刻板印象认为女性比男性道歉更多。我知道你在这一领域做过研究。你能告诉我们的听众你发现了什么吗？那个刻板印象是真的吗？是的，也不完全是。所以，是的。
Yeah, so when I started studying apologies way back in grad school, I came across the stereotype often. Women apologize all the time. Men apologize for nothing. Women apologize reflexively and without even giving it a second thought and our over-apologizers and men, you know, are unwilling to ever take responsibility. They have their egos, don't allow them to admit wrong, all this kind of stuff. So I wanted to see if this was true because there really wasn't a lot of empirical research to back up those stereotypes. And what I found across numerous studies was that women did apologize more frequently in their daily life. So when we tracked their apology behavior with diary studies, we did see a higher frequency. But we also saw a higher frequency
是的，所以当我还在研究生院开始研究道歉时，我经常遇到这种刻板印象。女性一直道歉。男性什么都不道歉。女性反射性地道歉，甚至不假思索，是过度道歉者，而男性，你知道，不愿意承担任何责任。他们有他们的自尊，不允许他们承认错误，所有这些东西。所以我想要看看这是不是真的，因为确实没有太多的实证研究来支持这些刻板印象。我在众多研究中发现的是，女性在日常生活中道歉的频率确实更高。所以当我们通过日记研究追踪她们的道歉行为时，我们确实看到了更高的频率。但我们也看到了更高的频率
of offenses reported. And what that means is when we looked at the proportion of offenses that they were apologizing for, it was identical to men's proportion of offenses that they were apologizing for. And we also saw this from the victim's perspective. So when we asked them to report things that they had been offended by and had received an apology for, we saw a similar pattern where women were reporting more offenses on the receiving end than men were reporting as victims. And so this made us think, is there a difference in perceptions of severity here? Where, men are less likely to see an offense as occurring or less likely to see behaviors as warranting an apology because they just don't see it as bothersome as women see it. And so we tested this
报告的冒犯。这意味着当我们查看她们道歉的冒犯比例时，它与男性道歉的冒犯比例是相同的。我们也从受害者的角度看到了这一点。所以当我们要求他们报告他们被冒犯并收到道歉的事情时，我们看到了类似的模式，女性报告的受害者端的冒犯比男性报告的要多。所以这让我们思考，这里对严重程度的看法有差异吗？男性不太可能认为冒犯发生了，或者不太可能认为行为值得道歉，因为他们只是不像女性那样认为它令人困扰。所以我们测试了这个
in a bunch of follow-up studies with more controlled methods where we gave men and women the exact same offenses and we had them rate how severe they were and how much an apology was deserved and how likely they were to apologize. And what we saw consistently, study after study was that men and women saw the identical offenses differently. So women rated them as more severe, more deserving of an apology, and therefore rated themselves as more likely to apologize. So what does this all mean? What it means is that, yes, women do apologize more frequently than men in their daily lives, although I will say that this difference is much smaller than the stereotype suggests. So this is not men are from Mars. What is it? Women are from, you
在一堆后续研究中，使用更受控的方法，我们给男性和女性完全相同的冒犯，让他们评价它们有多严重，道歉有多值得，以及他们道歉的可能性有多大。我们始终看到，研究又研究，男性和女性对相同的冒犯看法不同。所以女性评价它们更严重，更值得道歉，因此评价自己道歉的可能性更高。那么这一切意味着什么？这意味着，是的，女性在日常生活中道歉的频率确实比男性高，尽管我会说这种差异比刻板印象所暗示的要小得多。所以这不是“男人来自火星”。这是什么？“女人来自，你
Yeah, women are from Venus, yeah. This is not two bipolar behaviors here where they're completely on opposite ends of the spectrum. These are small differences in frequency where women are slightly more likely to apologize in their daily lives.
是的，女人来自金星，是的。这里不是两种双极行为，它们完全处于光谱的两端。这些是频率上的微小差异，女性在日常生活中道歉的可能性略高。
And the reason why this difference is emerging, at least in part, is because women are seeing these offenses as these behaviors as more offensive and therefore more deserving an apology. And when men register a behavior as offensive, they are quite willing, just as willing as women to apologize for it. And our research shows that they apologize in equally high-quality ways. So men's men and women's apologies are actually quite similar in the way they're structured.
而这种差异出现的原因，至少部分是因为女性认为这些冒犯，这些行为更具冒犯性，因此更值得道歉。当男性将一种行为登记为冒犯性时，他们非常愿意，和女性一样愿意为此道歉。我们的研究表明，他们以同样高质量的方式道歉。所以男性和女性的道歉在结构上实际上非常相似。
So it's not that women, you know, are falling over themselves offering these really comprehensive, amazing apologies, whereas men are just like, sorry about that, you know. It's their apologies are actually quite similar as well. So, yeah, the stereotype has some bones to it, but not nearly to the extent that people think that men are really unwilling to apologize. One thing I will say as a follow-up to that is that it really implies that communication is really important, especially in our mixed-gender relationships. So women really need to sort of remember that men might have a different advantage
所以并不是说女性，你知道，为了提供这些非常全面、令人惊叹的道歉而跌跌撞撞，而男性只是像，“对此感到抱歉”，你知道。他们的道歉实际上也非常相似。所以，是的，刻板印象有一些根据，但远没有人们认为的男性真的不愿意道歉的程度。作为后续，我想说的一件事是，它确实意味着沟通非常重要，特别是在我们的混合性别关系中。所以女性确实需要记住，男性可能有不同的优势
point, a different perception of the behavior that they have, and that they can communicate that, you know, they were harmed or they feel hurt by the behavior because that might not have sort of crossed men's, the man's threshold as being offensive, so to speak. And men also have a responsibility to remember that women might be more upset about something than they are. And that's where communication comes in, right, to really, especially in, you know, heterosexual romantic relationships, But across all relationships, of course, this is important to really communicate about how you're feeling, about why you're hurt, and without doing it in a blaming or critical way to try to have a constructive conversation about your emotions and feelings about the situation
点，对他们所拥有的行为有不同的看法，并且他们可以沟通，你知道，他们受到了伤害，或者他们对这种行为感到受伤，因为那可能没有像那样跨越男性的，男性的门槛，被认为是冒犯性的。男性也有责任记住，女性可能对某事比他们更不安。这就是沟通发挥作用的地方，对吧，去真正地，特别是在，你知道，异性恋浪漫关系中，但在所有关系中，当然，这对于真正沟通你的感受，关于你为什么受伤，以及在不以指责或批评的方式去做的情况下，尝试就你对这种情况的情绪和感受进行建设性的对话非常重要
so that you can bring each other onto the same page. Now, you've also looked at differences between conservatives and liberals when it comes to apologizing. which I think is pretty interesting. And can you tell us what you found there? Yeah. So this is work that was led by Dr. Matthew Hornsey. What we found was that liberals are, again, slightly more willing to apologize than conservatives are.
这样你们就能把彼此带到同一个页面上。现在，你还研究了保守派和自由派在道歉方面的差异。我认为这很有趣。你能告诉我们你在那里发现了什么吗？是的。所以这是由马修·霍恩西博士领导的工作。我们发现的是，自由派，再次，比保守派更愿意道歉。
And they're also slightly more happy to receive an apology or the apology has a stronger effect on their willingness to forgive than it does for conservatives. conservatives. There's a few reasons why we think this is the case. Liberals are also slightly more likely to have a growth mindset of personality, so they're slightly more likely to believe that people can change, and therefore apologies might be a stronger signal of that change for them or that capacity for improvement. And liberals are also less likely to have what we call social dominance orientation or a high social dominance orientation, which is
而且他们也稍微更乐于收到道歉，或者道歉对他们宽恕意愿的影响比对保守派更强。保守派。我们认为这是这种情况的原因有几个。自由派也稍微更有可能拥有成长型人格思维，所以他们稍微更有可能相信人们可以改变，因此道歉对他们来说可能是那种改变或那种改进能力的更强信号。而且自由派也不太可能拥有我们所说的社会支配倾向或高社会支配倾向，这是
a tendency to be okay with hierarchy and a hierarchical structure between people. And so liberals feel a little bit less comfortable with inequality and feeling like things aren't fair between groups. And that might translate into our conflict situations where an offense can create an inequality between the transgressor and victim. And so apologies sort of can help remedy that. And therefore, liberals are potentially slightly more willing to offer those apologies and be happy to receive an apology. It's a little bit of a complicated relationship there. But again, these differences, I want to just make sure I convey. They're not extremely huge.
一种倾向于接受等级制度和人与人之间等级结构的倾向。所以自由派对不平等和感觉群体之间事情不公平感到有点不舒服。这可能会转化为我们的冲突情况，其中冒犯会在违规者和受害者之间造成不平等。所以道歉在某种程度上可以帮助补救这一点。因此，自由派可能稍微更愿意提供那些道歉并乐于收到道歉。那里有一点复杂的关系。但再次，这些差异，我只是想确保我传达出来。它们不是非常巨大。
These are small differences, but they are consistent. You've also done research that suggests that people who are harder on themselves are less likely to forgive themselves for mistakes and less likely to apologize to others. Can you talk a little bit about that work? Yes. So self-compassion is our tendency to not let ourselves off the hook easily for things, but to give ourselves some breathing room and to say, you know, I know I make mistakes and I'm human and that's okay. And what happens is when people are higher in self-compassion, they are less likely to hide from their mistakes or run away from their mistakes in shame because they say, you know, they're more willing to recognize, I understand
这些是微小的差异，但它们是一致的。你还做过研究，表明对自己更严厉的人不太可能原谅自己的错误，也不太可能向他人道歉。你能谈谈那项工作吗？是的。所以自我同情是我们倾向于不轻易放过自己，而是给自己一些喘息的空间，并说，“你知道，我知道我犯了错误，我是人类，那没关系。”发生的事情是，当人们自我同情程度更高时，他们不太可能因为羞耻而躲避错误或逃避错误，因为他们说，“你知道，他们更愿意认识到，我理解
I'm not perfect and I can fix this and I can grow from this. And so instead of, you know, ignoring the problem and hiding in shame and failing to address the problem because of that shame, they're more willing to confront their actions and sort of experience that discomfort that comes with recognizing that you've harmed someone and sort of sit in that guilt and discomfort a little bit because of that self-compassion that they then have to say, this is okay to have done this and not to have done it, but to recognize that I'm not perfect and that I can grow from this. So that's what we find that self-compassion is associated with less shame and therefore more
我不完美，我可以修复这个，我可以从中成长。”所以，而不是，你知道，忽视问题并躲在羞耻中，因为那种羞耻而未能解决问题，他们更愿意面对他们的行为，并体验那种伴随着认识到你伤害了某人而来的不适，并因为那种自我同情而稍微坐在那种内疚和不适中，他们然后不得不说，“做这件事没关系，没做这件事也没关系，但要认识到我不完美，我可以从中成长。”所以这就是我们发现的，自我同情与更少的羞耻感相关联，因此更多
willingness to apologize because you're willing to really kind of address and sit in the discomfort that comes with the recognition that you harm someone. What about those people who apologize all the time, even when there's really nothing to apologize for? It's sort of like a verbal tick. Are these people viewed differently from people who don't do that? I mean, are they seen as maybe weaker or less competent? Or are they seen as maybe being nicer than other people? A little bit of both. So we have a number of studies looking at this. And what we found was that people who have high baselines, high apology baselines.
愿意道歉，因为你愿意真正地去处理并坐在那种伴随着认识到你伤害了某人而来的不适中。那些一直道歉的人，即使真的没什么可道歉的，怎么样？这有点像口头禅。这些人与不这样做的人相比，看法不同吗？我的意思是，他们被视为可能更软弱或能力更差吗？或者他们被视为可能比其他人更友善吗？有点两者兼有。所以我们有许多研究在看这一点。我们发现的是，那些有高基线，高道歉基线的人。
So they apologize very frequently, very often for things, you know, certainly for things that warrant an apology, but also for things that could have gone without an apology. And so what we found is that people with these high apology baselines, they are seen as slightly less competent and less, more. more so less assertive. I would say that the association with competency was weak, but they're seen as less assertive and a little bit less powerful. But those correlations were pretty small. And what we found was a much stronger correlation with being seen as very warm and moral and relational and caring. And so it seems like being a high baseline apology apologizer has some slight. cost in terms of being seen as less assertive, but some strong benefits in terms of being seen
所以他们道歉非常频繁，经常为一些事情道歉，当然，有些事情确实值得道歉，但也有一些事情其实没必要道歉。我们发现，那些道歉基准线很高的人，会被认为能力稍弱，而且更不果断。我想说，这种与能力的关联很弱，但他们确实被认为不够果断，影响力也稍弱一些。不过这些相关性非常小。我们发现，与被视为非常温暖、有道德、重情义和有爱心的人相比，这种相关性要强得多。因此，作为一个高频率道歉者似乎在被认为不够果断方面有一些轻微的代价，但在被视为温暖、有爱心、有道德的人方面却有很大的好处。
as a worn, caring, moral person. What we also found really interestingly, and we didn't actually have prophesize this in advance, but what we found is that people who are high-based apologizers, but who are also seen as offering high-quality apologies. So apologies that are sincere and comprehensive and not defensive, when they have that combination of being a high-frequency apologizer, but being a good apologizer, they do not have that cost to their assertiveness. They're simply seen as more warm and moral, and it's not associated with a hit to your assertiveness or power. So I would say if you're going to be a high-frequency apologizer and apologize for everything, just make sure you're apologizing well. Now, up until this point,
作为一个温暖、有爱心、有道德的人。我们还发现了一个非常有趣的结果，虽然我们事先并没有预料到，但我们发现，那些高频率道歉者，如果同时被认为能提供高质量的道歉，即真诚、全面且不推卸责任的道歉，那么当他们具备这种“高频率道歉者”但同时又是“优秀的道歉者”的特质时，他们就不会在果断性上付出代价。他们只会显得更温暖、更有道德，这并不会损害他们的果断性或影响力。所以我想说，如果你打算做一个高频率道歉者，为每件事都道歉，那就确保你道歉的方式是得体的。现在，到目前为止，
talked a lot about interpersonal kind of one-on-one apologies, but what about institutional apologies? I raised this because a lot of organizations, including my organization, APA, have in the past few years begun to take stock of their history and apologize for harm they've caused to other people in the past, especially around issues like race and racism. Do you think that these institutional apologies are effective and really have a role in addressing and correcting historical injustice? I think they certainly have a role. I think they are necessary.
我们谈了很多关于人际间一对一的道歉，但机构道歉又如何呢？我提出这一点是因为许多组织，包括我所在的美国心理学会（APA），在过去几年里开始审视自己的历史，并为过去对他人造成的伤害道歉，特别是在种族和种族主义等问题上。你认为这些机构道歉有效吗？它们在解决和纠正历史不公方面真的有作用吗？我认为它们当然有作用。我认为它们是必要的。
I don't think that they, in and of themselves, can do all of the repair, can do all of the work. As I said before with more severe harms in our interpersonal conflicts, I would like to suggest that they are a starting point. They send a signal, we care about this. This matters. We are committed to do. doing better. Without an apology in these situations, it's almost like being complicit and that
我不认为它们本身就能完成所有的修复工作，就能解决所有问题。正如我之前所说，在人际冲突中面对更严重的伤害时，我想建议它们是一个起点。它们传递了一个信号：我们在乎这件事。这很重要。我们致力于做得更好。在这些情况下，如果不道歉，就几乎等同于同谋，而那种
silence, that unwillingness to acknowledge the harm that's been done, that unwillingness to make that formal step of saying, this was wrong, we did this, we have learned, and we're going to continue to put in the work to learn. Without that, you're not able to send that very clear signal and make that clear commitment. And so I think they absolutely have a place. I think they're really important. But they really have to be a starting point. They have to be a cog in a larger puzzle of commitment to change and listening and learning and making sure that these types of things don't continue to occur. Because it really is a long process, especially when we're talking about issues related to equity, diversity, and inclusion,
沉默，那种不愿承认所造成伤害的意愿，那种不愿迈出正式的一步去说“这是错的，我们做了这件事，我们已经吸取了教训，我们将继续努力学习”的意愿，如果没有这些，你就无法发出那个非常明确的信号并做出明确的承诺。所以我认为它们绝对有一席之地。我认为它们非常重要。但它们确实必须是一个起点。它们必须是致力于改变、倾听、学习并确保此类事件不再发生的更大拼图中的一个齿轮。因为这确实是一个漫长的过程，特别是在我们谈论与公平、多样性和包容性相关的问题时，
and the history of marginalization that we've seen in all kinds of organizations and governments. So I think we have to have realistic expectations of these apologies. They certainly cannot write the wrongs of the past, but they are an important step in doing so. Last question, one that I like to ask a lot of the researchers I talk to. What's next? What are the big questions that you're looking at? at now. Right now, we are continuing to do work on interpersonal apologies, looking at, you know, what are some of the downsides of apologies? Can they make someone less likely to behave morally in the
以及我们在各种组织和政府中看到的边缘化历史。所以我认为我们必须对这些道歉有现实的期望。它们当然无法纠正过去的错误，但它们是纠正错误的重要一步。最后一个问题，我喜欢问我采访的许多研究人员：接下来是什么？你现在正在关注哪些重大问题？目前，我们正在继续进行人际道歉方面的研究，看看道歉有哪些负面影响？它们是否会让人在未来不太可能表现得有道德？
future? So, you know, you feel this boost after you've apologized to your moral self. Does that then make you less likely to do the right thing in that relationship moving forward? Or does it make you more likely to behave in a morally consistent manner with them? So that's a really interesting question to us. We're also looking at the role of apologies in the political domain. So we have a lot of political conflict. And in addition to looking at apologies in that space, we've been looking at how to reduce political hostility in this country, which we know is very divided. So how can we, how can we create harmony and willingness to understand and listen and empathize with members, of our political outgroups and what role do apologies have in smoothing over those relationships
所以，你在道歉后会感到道德感提升，这是否会让你在未来的关系中不太可能做正确的事？还是说这会让你更有可能与他们保持道德一致的行为？这对我们来说是一个非常有趣的问题。我们也在研究道歉在政治领域的作用。我们有很多政治冲突。除了研究该领域的道歉外，我们一直在研究如何减少这个国家的政治敌意，我们知道这个国家分歧很大。那么，我们如何才能创造和谐，以及理解、倾听和同情我们政治对立群体成员的意愿？道歉在缓和这些关系方面有什么作用？
once there has been an offense committed, those kinds of questions. But really, you know, apologies, we even came up with some questions in this session that we don't yet know the answers. Are there specific ways to apologize that are really important and that are really effective? And are there relationship types where apologies are most effective? or least effective and all kinds of questions that have yet to be answered. So we're continuing our work in this space. But yeah, it's always exciting. It's something that people can really relate to in their lives. And it's always exciting to learn more about how they can resolve their conflicts and improve their relationships. I want to thank you for joining me today, Dr. Schumann. I think
一旦发生了冒犯行为，这些都是我们需要探讨的问题。但说真的，我们甚至在这次会议中提出了一些我们还不知道答案的问题。是否有特定的道歉方式是非常重要且有效的？是否存在道歉最有效或最无效的关系类型？还有各种各样的问题尚未得到解答。所以我们正在继续在这个领域进行研究。但这总是令人兴奋的。这是人们在生活中真正能产生共鸣的事情。了解他们如何解决冲突并改善关系总是令人兴奋的。舒曼博士，我想感谢你今天加入我的节目。我想
you've given our listeners some important advice and some things to think about. Well, thank you so much for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.combeingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you hear, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondayan. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你给了我们的听众一些重要的建议和思考。好的，非常感谢邀请我。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Weinerman 制作。我们的音效编辑是 Chris Kondayan。感谢收听，我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。